a local group of moms were able to get  full vip spa  treatment just ahead of mother's day  capelli salon partnered with t3 micro in  freedom and fashion  to make it all happen freedom and  fashion is a local non-profit that uses  beauty  and fashion to empower women to overcome  things like sex  trafficking and domestic violence both  of those have  spiked during the pandemic as more and  more people were home  it's really important now more than ever  that we raise awareness not only of the  issue and the injustice and the crime  but also of the strength of the people  persevering through this which  being a mother is hard enough as it is  doing it during a pandemic when you're  overcoming sex trafficking and domestic  violence  they're among the strongest people on  earth delgado went on to say the purpose  of today's event is to remind the moms  to feel good about themselves and the  beauty they have inside